ihre geschichte klingt wie ein märchen
sunita alizadeh 19 jahre alt vor einem
jahr noch eine illegale afghanische
immigrantinnen teheran heute eine
selbstbestimmte junge frau nun kann ich
reisen die ganze welt bereist denn ich
habe einen pass ich gehe in die schule
in eine richtige schule zum aller ersten
mal in meinem leben ich darf lernen und
ich fühle mich sehr sicher
die geschichte beginnt in teheran wo
afghanische kriegsflüchtlinge rechtlos
und unerwünscht sind mit ihrer schwester
und ihrer nichte lebt sunita hier mehr
schlecht als recht
eine iranische organisation vermittelt
ihr etwas bildung und rap ist ihre
leidenschaft
ich träumte immer davon eine berühmte
rapperin zu werden die die wahrheit sagt
und die von den menschen unterstützt
wird mir ist es wichtig meine botschaft
rüberzubringen
sunita sinkt über kinderarbeit über das
dasein am rand der gesellschaft
dabei lernt sie die filmemacherin rock
sarah helmig in die sie nun drei jahre
lang mit der kamera begleiten wird
in dieser zeit kommt unitas mutter zu
besuch
mit einer bitteren nachricht zum etat
soll wie es die tradition will als braut
verkauft werden als meine mutter vor
allem preis sprache verschlug es mir die
sprache
ich suchte nach einem ausweg und dachte
ich möchte noch so vieles erreichen wenn
ich heiraten muss was geschieht dann mit
meiner zukunft meinen träumen
sunita will ihr schicksal nicht einfach
hinnehmen alleine stemmt sie sich gegen
die tradition mit einem klagelied
das video macht sie auf einen schlag
weltberühmt
es war eine schwierige entscheidung das
video auf youtube zu stellen
ich fürchte mich vor den reaktionen in
afghanistan und speziell jeder meiner
familie aber ich sagte mir ich muss es
tun selbst wenn ich mir damit schade
glücklicherweise hatte ich sofort viele
fans als meine mutter mich anrief sagte
sie sie finde den song gut
sie war zwar nicht wirklich glücklich
darüber aber dennoch für mich war das
der größte bank in meinem leben zum
ersten mal fühlt sie sich verstanden
heiraten muss sie nicht mehr stattdessen
darf sony tor nach amerika ausreißen
eine universität in utah bietet hier ein
stipendium für ein musikstudium an ihr
traum hat sich erfüllt
doch ihr kampf ist noch lange nicht zu
ende
mein traum ist es familien zu helfen
denn sie lieben ja ihre töchter und
wissen keinen anderen weg als sie zu
verheiraten
das ist mein größter wunsch
zwangsheiraten ein ende zu setzen
künftig will so mieter auch als
aktivistin für frauenrechte arbeiten
wer könnte das besser